in the first story we see a pregnant
woman who is crying and begging her
husband to not leave her it is the month
of December and the entire city is
covered in a thick blanket of snow the
woman can barely walk due to her
eight-month pregnancy but despite this
her husband is adamant on leaving he
says that he will be back in a few days
after Gathering some supplies before
going out though he hands her a jar of
magical Roots which will apparently
prevent the baby from being born 13
years passed by but the man is still not
returned the house is in a state of
utter chaos as we see maggots crawling
through the Sea of garbage and filth
miraculously the woman is still alive
and still pregnant The Roots seem to
have worked but the only problem is that
her baby is grown inside of her womb it
has now become the size of an adult
human because of which the woman is
unable to stand up or move properly wow
that thing's a bigger baby than idubbbz
she is still hopeful that her husband
will return soon and so she keeps
calling out his name shockingly the baby
inside of her womb is now started
talking it gender is not specified but
it can make genuine conversations with
the woman like asking her what they're
going to have for food or when his dad
coming or how many years until AI takes
over the planet one day the woman
catches someone's pet cat in her trap
and eats it for dinner while the ACT is
very ruthless and inhumane it is the
only way she can survive however she
lies to her baby that she cooked a
rabbit so as not to offend it that night
as the woman is getting ready to sleep
she experiences extreme contractions due
to her pregnancy she rushes to the jar
to ingest the root but sadly for her
they are no more it appears as if the
woman ate the last strand in the morning
the sight of the empty jar terrifies her
and she drops it to the floor crying
just then the baby inside of her
announces that it is coming out the
woman begs it to stop saying please
don't leave me but the baby is made up
its mind it simply says there is enough
room for the two of us
the next second the giant baby starts
twisting inside the woman's body causing
her to die in an instant then a gruesome
Montage shows the woman being completely
disemboweled by the baby
few hours later after the procedure ends
the baby in the body of its mother
stands up for the first time it cleans
up the excess Flesh on the floor throws
it outside and then sews its own stomach
some weeks later we see the baby living
a completely normal life it has made the
house neat and tidy along with itself
right then its father arrives at the
door after 13 long years he acts as if
he was only gone for a day or two the
baby looks at him in disbelief but the
man who is unaware of what happened
approaches it with lust in his eyes the
movie ends as he unzips the baby's
clothes to make romance with it are you
kidding are you kidding me that can't be
how that can't be How It Ends
I gotta draw some kind of line man the
second movie starts in a rural Village
in America where a six-year-old boy
named Troy lives with his parents his
dad Jeffrey is a Neo-Nazi skinhead who
despises everyone apart from his own
race Troy's mom Krista however is a
well-mannered and calm lady despite
being an Odd Couple the two love their
son a lot and always make sure that he
is happy one day they go on a trip with
some other neo-nazis and have a fun time
at the beach Jeffrey bets against
everyone that his son can land a perfect
aim of his rifle this gets everyone
excited so they bet 50 each to their
surprise the six-year-old expertly
manages to strike his Target from a
distance this makes Jeffrey very proud
and he quickly collects the winning cash
from his gang at night the family goes
to a department store to spend their
winnings Troy has given the freedom to
choose anything he wants including beer
and chocolate while they are at the
counter Troy spots a black man named JD
playing with a toy and innocently Smiles
at him JD also smiles back and the two
seem to have formed an instant bond
however their happy moment is rudely cut
short when the racist Jeffrey scolds the
man for looking at his son he even
speaks some racial slurs in front of
everyone as expected this enrages JD and
he curses at Jeffrey before leaving the
store unfortunately the altercation
turns out to be the start of a brutal
War Jeffrey who is infuriated that he
was cursed at immediately calls his gang
and asks them to arrive outside the
store Krista tries her best to calm her
husband down but all in vain even little
Troy can do nothing but watch his father
become aggressive more and more by the
second soon the gang arrives and they
beat the hell out of the man in front of
his own family JD's kids are terrified
inside their car but their screams and
cries for help only fall on deaf ears
after the Beatdown is done Jeffrey makes
sure to humiliate the poor man even more
by pouring a gallon of milk over his
face jokes on you [__] milk's delicious
all this is observed by one of JD's Sons
brawny who appears to have Vengeance in
his eyes the next morning Jeffrey takes
his son out for a ride as if nothing has
happened they hike the forest roam the
city and then prepare to return home at
night however on the way they are
stopped by a mysterious van which is
blocking the road as usual Jeffrey
becomes aggressive and gets out of his
car to take matters into his own hands
but when he approaches the van a group
of guys beats him up and loads him
inside little Troy notices this from his
car and he screams at the men to let his
dad go he even runs behind their van for
quite some distance but in the end he
gets tired and eventually gives up
surprisingly the perpetrator behind the
entire operation is revealed to be none
other than brawny he has meticulously
planned something evil to exact
Vengeance for what happened to his dad
in the next scene an unconscious Jeffrey
is brought to a shady looking apartment
where several of bronny's men tie him up
and start working on him at first they
inject him with various substances then
they shave his entire body they're
actually planning to tattoo him from top
to bottom the procedure takes several
days and by the end of it Jeffrey has
become completely unrecognizable one
night he is dropped off at the same
location where he was abducted due to
the large amounts of Narcotics present
inside his body Jeffrey is not able to
walk or talk properly so he drags
himself all the way home when he finally
sees himself in the car's mirror he has
taken aback to learn that he has become
completely black the gangsters have
tattooed every single inch of his body
as Jeffrey begins to panic Christus
suddenly wakes up from her sleep and
assumes that an intruder is trying to
barge into her house so she immediately
Springs into action and brings out a
handgun after she asks Troy to hide she
slowly heads towards the door to
confront the Intruder to her shock she
sees a dark completely undressed male
coming towards her Krista is about to
shoot at him but right then she realizes
that the man is actually her husband she
slowly lowers her weapon in disbelief
but the next second a loud bang is heard
and Jeffrey drops to the floor it turns
out little Troy has shot his own father
from behind mistaking him for an
intruder at the beginning of the third
story a young teenager named Isaiah is
clutching a photograph and beating his
meat when his dad Sydney suddenly walks
in the atmosphere is tense and awkward
for a few seconds but then Sydney
approaches his son and starts explaining
that this is very normal everyone does
it in their free time because it's a fun
thing to do when Isaiah nervously asks
his dad if he does it Sydney says yes
this makes the teenager a bit more
relaxed and he thanks his dad for being
an understanding person however when
Sydney leaves the room it is shockingly
revealed that the picture Isaiah was
holding on to belonged to none other
than his dad oh my
what is this what is this this is am I
being punished
14 years later it is the biggest day of
Isaiah's life he is getting married
however Sydney doesn't look happy at all
this is because he is constantly abused
and harassed by his own son even during
the family picture Isaiah cannot stop
running his fingers through his dad's
body later we see Sydney's wife Joan
chatting and having a good time with all
the guests but when she doesn't see her
husband and son around she becomes
worried and starts looking for them as
she reaches near the toilet she hears
some grunting sounds which she clearly
recognizes Joan nervously peeks through
the door and what she Witnesses sends
chills down her spine her own son is
doing it with her husband [__]
I have to narrate this this is my this
is my life days pass but Sydney is still
tormented by his son even his wife
doesn't do anything to stop the monster
with no one to call for help Sydney
pours out his entire story in a memoir
which he titles cocoon man unfortunately
he blames himself for being tough on his
son a pretty good name just like a
Metapod or a Kakuna he does appear to
know how to use Harden unfortunately he
blames himself for not being tough on
his son while he was growing up a few
months later Sydney finishes his Memoir
prints it and then leaves it in the
bedroom hoping that his wife can read it
whole and discover the tragic story he
is actually unaware that Jon already
knows the truth unfortunately before she
can come out of the bathroom Isaiah
finds the Memoir he angrily confronts
Sydney about it and also warns him
against making any copies in the future
Isaiah promises that he will unleash
hell on his dad if the same case repeats
again sadly the terrified old man has no
choice but to comply one day as Sydney
is relaxing in the bathtub wearing
headphones Isaiah suddenly starts
knocking on the door Sydney doesn't hear
it and this only makes the mod monster
more aggressive in a fit of rage he
breaks open the door and torments the
poor man making him scream for help
downstairs Joan hears everything but she
is too scared to react she simply turns
on the volume of her television and sobs
in despair this turns out to be the last
straw for Sydney so the next morning he
gathers enough courage and prints
another copy of the Memoir he now plans
to submit it to the nearest publication
and disclose all of his son's evil Deeds
but unfortunately just as he is about to
exit the house Isaiah catches him
red-handed he chastises his dad and
calls him a traitor saying he genuinely
loved him he also rants about how no one
ever cared about him and his family the
long and rage-filled speech certainly
moves Sydney but he quickly shakes off
his emotions to focus on his mission he
rushes out of the door and reaches the
road only to be hit by an oncoming truck
Isaiah Witnesses the whole incident and
becomes traumatized he holds his dad's
lifeless body and starts crying in the
middle of the road and soon after Jonah
also joins him in this way an innocent
kind and lovable man was killed because
of son's horrible actions cut to some
days later Sydney's funeral is organized
and several people have arrived to pay
their respects to the well-respected
writer this is when a grief-stricken
Joan finally decides to confront her son
she Corners him in a room and asks when
did it start as expected Isaiah tries to
divert the topic but Joan doesn't budge
when the conversation gets heated she
slaps him right across the face and he
does the same then they start striking
each other with random objects due to
his physical presence Isaiah gains the
upper hands and is about to shove Joan
into a lit fireplace but luckily she
finds a fire iron and hits him with it
she then stabs him several times until
he stops moving the movie ends with
Jones gut-wrenching cries in a matter of
days she has lost her entire family kind
of sick
[Music]
holy God I'm sorry okay I'm sorry
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching